whether you consider Lena with the other
guy's situation to be an L or a w
doesn't even matter in your world
because it just made you get tons of
attention yeah when you guys agree to
the Jason love thing was there ever a
moment in time where you might have
thought oh this might have been a bad
idea yeah after she did it for sure
it's like the the sort of like just a
weird like feeling in the stomach of
just like oh dude like is this a good
idea what did you do when she was like
when she's like okay bye I'm gonna go
did you go to Baskin Robbins and have an
ice cream by yourself or like what would
you do there there's nothing that like
would take my mind off of my wife
getting [__] by this big ass black guy
more than like me playing poker
tournaments so that's what I was doing
all day when she came back from the
scene was there any sort of like
awkwardness
she came back and it was all good like
she got Dave's Hot Chicken delivered so
that was pretty dope and then we talked
about it and then we ended up hooking up